Nèa hai mấy bài tháng 5, ngoài trường Mỹ Macorabio đã chỉ đạo toàn bộ đại xe quan và lãnh sử quán Mỹ trên thế giới.
Tạm dừng xếm lịch phòng vấn mới, đối với các đơn xin thị thử dụng học và chào đối, loại FM và G.
Cuối đình của hiệu lượng ngày lập tất và được xem là bước trình Mỹ cho việc mừng giống kiểm tra bất bộ mặt sã hội như Instagram直 Talk,
để tiêm kiểm lỗi dung đe sóa tế anh hình cú sa của các dù học sinh.
Thà bộ ngoại sống Mỹ, hướng tán chí tế sẽ được công bố trong phản hệ tới, các cuộc phòng vấn đề được lịch chức vẫn được phát tiến hành.
Chí tìm mới năm trong bối cảnh chính quyền tổng thống trong tăng cử biển pháp hạnh chế nhập cảnh đối với xin biên của tế.
Theo một số mòn tìm, cuối định này lên quan để lòng ngày vừa sử lâm chuyển tức tưởng bài sâu thái và các hạt động phản đối chính xe quý xa raen.
Về tạm dừng phòng vấn tì thơ có thể làm giám đoạn đáng kể quá trình xử liệu hồ sơ dù học.
Lấy thị thải chuyên nhiều trường đau trạnh Mỹ, bố năm phổ thục lẫn và học phi của sinh viên của tế.
Hẹn bộ ngoại sông Mỹ và các tổ chức sắc số của tế chưa đưa ra bình luận chính thức về quy định này.